[Applause]
about the back of the jerseys so like
the MBA said you can put whatever not
whatever you want there's like a list of
approved things to put on your back of
your Jersey yeah you're right yeah can
you get those up which of the other ones
but like you can put black lives matter
like Kyle Korver's - and black lives
matter you can excuse me make a
statement with where your name would go
on the Jersey read about this
hey I've read about I didn't know
they're gonna go through with it so yeah
they've gone through with it they have a
list of things that guys can put on the
back of their Jersey and it was part of
the negotiation of the players coming
back to the bubble and the different
things that they can do to promote black
lives matter and promote promote
everything that's going on and so black
lives matters actually can you remove
that a little harder for me to read
black lives matter say their name names
vote I can't breathe justice peace
equality freedom enough power to the
people justice now say her name
see sip way they liberation see us hear
us respect does love us listen listen to
a stand up ally anti-racist I am a man
okay yo it's a little problematic wmba
juries gonna be speak up how many more
group economics education reform and
mentor so you can put any of those
approved on the back and LeBron and I
believe Kauai a bunch of players have
chose not to do it
hmm and their argument is you know what
I do for the community you know and it's
undeniable what he does for the
community it is interesting though does
he view that as performative and not
really doing change and is he saying hey
this isn't really how you make a
difference like but he's warned and I
can't breathe shirt in pregame warmup
and also I would say that like so for
his argument I go Metta World Peace
didn't make more World Peace hmm right
does it just seem like a gimmick and
maybe he's is he like look having that
on the back of my Jersey is gonna make
more people realize that black lives
matter mmm I
thing personally and maybe he has the
same thing where it's like I don't want
to feel like I'm caving to social
pressure to be woke like I'll do it if I
want to do it I'm not gonna do it
because you're telling me like the black
square on Instagram I was like I'm not
doing it just because they negotiated
for this not the NBA this is the Players
Association group there might be a lot
of pressure internally to be like hey
guys we should all do this and he's
probably like I'm gonna do what I'm
gonna do I do plenty I'm not doing it
cuz you want me to I'm doing it cuz I
want to right but it is interesting
because he wore that I can't breathe
shirt on the court must have been
valuable I would like to know his
rationale for cuz some people might go
like oh this is from him or this is what
you think no no this is not from him
some people might say he said that he's
gonna wear James on the back of his
jersey that's that's what he didn't say
why no no well he said like you know
what I do and people know yeah but what
I'm saying is like some people might go
it's easy to talk about reform and all
that kind of stuff on Twitter but the
second you have to sacrifice something
there's like part of your personal
branding all of a sudden you're like you
know what I do
the second it doesn't say your name on a
doesn't say King James or the back say
James keep it a buck two if you want to
talk about like a lot of these things
don't really carry weight but if LeBron
James wins a fourth title whatever it is
with I can't breathe or I am a male and
any one of those things on the back is
Jersey that's a powerful image that
lives on forever you won the
championship wearing that Jersey with
that on your back that carries through
four generations that image I mean think
about all the pictures that will be
taken like on the court yonks and not
even championship just throughout the
season some crazy dunk you're elevating
and in the back it says black lives
matter and you're dunking on some white
guy like Debbie there'd be like some
pretty iconic crazy images that I really
don't know why some people might knock
there it could be like an ego things
like Whaley I got it not have my name on
the back is named LeBron James that's
what some people might say Kawai say
he's not gonna do it either cause so
locked in I don't think he even knows
what I don't think he knows people are
dying yeah yeah I can't breathe he's
like we'll just try to breathe
that seems like easiest way to breathe
he's like pregnant women do it
it's just interesting to me I don't know
it's just very interesting when given
the idea ability to do it a very small
thing the choice to not do it it doesn't
cost anything I know that's odd right I
thought you were gonna talk about the
MBA website and their ability to let you
customize jerseys on there have you seen
this No so like with in conjunction with
this thing
yeah the NBA website was like you know
if you want to order jerseys you can
order jerseys and customize the back to
whatever you want right except for a few
certain things what all eyes the one
that you can't that a lot of people are
talking about is free Hong Kong Wow into
the website it says we're unable to
customize this item with the text you
have entered please try a different
entry Wow and then people have like this
litany of awful things that you can have
instead you can have like [ __ ] police
kill cops burn Jews all on the back here
Jersey accept free Hong Kong I don't
know what the official list is as far as
like what's banned it was not so they
have the all these terrible things on
the back of the jerseys but the one that
they aren't allowing people to buy is
free Hong Kong if you guys hear the bark
and ask cookie in the back um you know
that is crazy they will really just bend
over and get [ __ ] they will get bet
the NBA will bend over and get [ __ ] by
China huh yo any crazy there the entire
reason you're in this [ __ ] bubble
China and you you boss a free Hong Kong
that's embarrassing yo yeah as well
that's wild yeah yeah that's um if
Andrew starts a pandemic and you all say
[ __ ] Andrew no matter how much money you
put in my pocket I'll be like I get it
never wear the jersey might get it
that's the thing man it's just so weird
like it's not weird as embarrassing well
that's what that's what things happen
when you start to question the care of a
corporation and that's why it's so hard
for corporations to be woke is because
there's always going to be a part of
that corporation that is gonna put
profit ahead of people hmm
and if you're a corporation all your
detractors have to do is find out what
that part of your hypocrisy lies and
then they can expose it like right now
these people that are finally you can't
say free Hong Kong they're just people
that don't care I imagine a lot of them
don't even care about Hong Kong they're
anti black lies they're antagonizing
their yeah they're doing this complete
to antagonize but you leave yourself
open to an attack on ization when you
become this fake whoa corporation but as
a as a pretty moderate person I think
that doesn't make me less black lives
matter but it does make me more yeah the
NBA man phony [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
you're doing right
I still black lives matter but also
yelling [ __ ] well that's the thing and
they're gonna go you don't care about
black lives matter you care about profit
and you realize that right now being on
the side of black lives matter is
profitable so like it really takes away
from any efforts you made at all and
that's why they're starting to seize it
now they're like yo we got money to make
y'all ready yeah nobody's watching TV
you all ready to make some money what's
the best way for us to make money okay
the black players don't want to play
because of black lives matter protests
and there's this monumental moment in
history we have all this attention all
right how can we trick them in a plan
well donate some money for black guys
man
well let's put black girls mad on you
Jersey what did it your goal is not help
black lives matter if you really care
about black girls matter you would shut
down a season and you bet we are
protesting with our players there's 90
percent black only and we are going to
and you know what we have all these
billionaire owners that have tons of
money we're also gonna donate money to
these different organizations these
different charities you don't give a
flying [ __ ] don't give them you are
given enough of a [ __ ] to make people
think that you do that's all it is
here's enough love [ __ ] to throw the
scent off to not give a [ __ ] trail yeah
they don't give a [ __ ] they give enough
of you give enough of a [ __ ] to trick
the populace yeah god damn that's
embarrassing yeah what was his woge
story oh just was fake KarenT some
senator said some [ __ ] what was it no
some sara said some [ __ ] he was like
[ __ ] you yeah and it's like it's
approach from [ __ ] I think [ __ ] but then
yes being suspended they suspended him
but like
well here's my thing Rhodes has a job
because of his connections right when
your woes what well guys if you don't
know who Adrian whoa Jen now ski or
whatever he's the type he's a guy who
drops news about trades drops news about
injuries drops any kind of news right
and they called woes BOM TMZ in the NBA
perfectly said yes
so his currency is relationships so his
relationship to the owner the Knicks his
relationship to the GM his relationship
with one of the training guys his
relationship to the players themselves
when the players themselves see this
yeah you know whose side they're gonna
be on what who tweeted him one of the
first people who tweeted him LeBron free
whoa free whoa
so now we'll the bran texts not Hong
Kong but whoa but now when washed X
LeBron hey what's going on the bubble
how's everything going LeBron might give
them a little tidbit well I might tell
them a little something like that you
choose your sources who you give the
information to and they scratch your
back too every once in a while Woods
writes an article about the best GM's in
the league and you know who he does he
scratches the back of those GM's that
gave him information you know he leaves
off the [ __ ] to say [ __ ] you you
serve saying all this is exchange of
information it's like spy ship and those
steaks yeah you know so I think what he
did was on perp if I'm wash I'd do that
on purpose and I make sure to leak my
own [ __ ] right you might get suspended
for a few days from ESPN but ESPN knows
what time it is
ain't knows good politicians these guys
I'm rember we're at the all-star game
and I saw shams they yeah Indian guy and
he's fine Indian whoa I didn't even work
for woosh he ate it I don't think now
he's number two is I'm really like
[ __ ] wire [ __ ]
but he got blew right past me and then
he we're with an MBA guy he was like hey
buddy
mad like talking him up and then I felt
a little hurt hmm but then I was also I
went to the NBA guys like are y'all like
homeys and he was like nah man he's just
trying to get something out of me that's
just what it is that's the game
but like it's call him by his last name
like if I was like yo Gagnon what's good
but like really trying to make you seem
like we're buddies they're just glad
handing yo hey let me hold this baby let
me take this picture I'm right there I'm
your guy tell me
something
[Applause]